[Music]
what up reject nation i like to yell at
the microphone for no reason guys we're
going to watch moon night episode
4 today if you want to catch our full
length reaction watch along where do
they go koi the patreon
time to jump that's why koi's not part
of it i'm not
support them emotionally become a
superject today that's a check out
everything we got over there but if you
can't do that leave a like that mean a
lot and tell us your thoughts on episode
four because if you're watching this
you've probably already seen it prepper
boys thanks for helping us edit these
down let's get to it
[Music]
oh no jesus
[Music]
would they not check inside the truck
the one place someone would hide
only what you can see
not leaving our own truck
you gotta treat him like a t-rex
[Music]
you guys suck at your job you know we're
going to need mark yeah
exactly see she gets
[Laughter]
i hadn't
hadn't disappeared from your life
already
yeah i mean whatever suit was his best
feature wasn't it didn't even have that
anymore stephen
right now i need to yell at layla
[Music]
he said goat earlier i wonder if
harrow has goat spies
when he pointed and said goats maybe
it's nasher and the other thor one i
don't trust that goat oh you're in love
with my wife i appreciate your concern
mate i really do lay one finger on you
got it from here i swear to you stephen
i swear i need a recipe for a protein
shake or
something shake made out of sand
you smell like him
of course he does i mean why wouldn't
you right
mark's trying to yeah you from conscious
that's why he's been pushing you away he
he thinks conscious wants you for his
avatar and he won't let that happen
that's where i just thought i felt like
you should know that
oh stephen you're a good guy what a good
guy i would have taken the kiss blocking
himself
virtue i don't need protection
what i need is honesty
miss knight honesty yeah
being honest
[Music]
oh
buddy smooth operator you know down okay
first
before i believe thank you
what was belay i still can't tell when
you're joking or not
[Laughter]
a plus
i love their two experiences that kiss
that
they're just like
i'm standing is that bast the black
panther guard so if they just sprang to
life right now and
ask me a riddle for passage i'd be
thrilled
[Laughter]
it's a maze
it's amazing
[Laughter]
they were so smart to go with that
personality leaving the show it's
amazing and this long
line ending in a spiral
is the tongue the avatar would be
on its voice that's clever holy balls
you think we'll go to the afterlife in
this one could
oh god is that fresh blood
oh yeah
oh yeah let's get some canopic jars
this is what kevin feige's like we're
pushing boundaries
the remnants of violence
i'm just like i'm just saying what i see
and
see lots of bones and blood going that
way
so i'm just thinking like
all right
good
it makes me laugh how there was barely
any moon night and now he doesn't have
the suit in the fourth episode
yeah yeah
yeah we can go this way
oh no leila get up there
[Music]
that's someone with no tongue oh [ __ ]
creepy
oh yeah
oh dude you gotta go into the nose
dude let marks take over
[Music]
let mark take over
my
[Music]
this is exciting
this is a better uncharted movie than
uncharted
this is
this show just feels like a theme park
to me i love it so much
ho ho
what's happening here she got grabbed
and pulled back and then again
i just want to know what's happening
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hopefully she landed on beds okay
there's no ledge your hero can't catch
that's why conschu wants you
her being sane and as formidable as mark
he's she's definitely a better avatar
yeah
oh this [ __ ] guy man
he's not going around that ledge with
those shoes though not those glass shoes
oh wow look at that look at all these
relics
it's going to be apocalypse in there
another oscar island i think we're
looking
at the long lost tomb
of alexander the great
or king the conqueror
alexander was the voice of ahmed
i'm gonna try
[Music]
something mr
[Music]
your father was murdered by mercenaries
and no one knows who they were today
mark remembers everything that happened
that day but one man stands out a man
with a fuchsia scarf made by his
daughter perhaps
i do hope you find closure
wake up
[Music]
that's not nearly enough information to
find closure with them man
[Music]
there we go yeah
later gators
i'm talking to you mark
right now what happened
to my listen today you can
of course not
but you were there i was there
yeah i was there
how did he die my partner got greedy and
he he executed everyone at dick's site
he shot me too i was supposed to die
that night
that's the reason that we met
you just had it guilty conscience
they're here
[Music]
let's be another way out
go find it i'll hold them off she's a
hell of an actress man oh absolutely
nice
oh [ __ ]
i can't save anyone who won't save
themselves
[Music]
oh my god make the deal again being
reborn and baptized
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna go to the sunken place
a hell of a shot it's beautiful
wow
oh i got nipple chills
the four matches change
yeah
that's young mark spector can you tell
oh there it is i want your history
[Laughter]
you're doctor stephen grant
might be strong
oh [ __ ] feels like a 90s tv show next
one we've got
beans
i can't believe they're doing this
[Music]
22 don't be afraid to speak up b-22 come
on everyone it's going to be the
straightjacket shot it's going to be the
smallwood lemire shot
jacket
this is beautiful
[Music]
wow is my blowing
i did not think they would do this it's
been five times this week
it's a lot
um
she's got the turkish delight again
we won
[Music]
i won
we have a winner
[Music]
yes
i know that you're having a great deal
of difficulty
[ __ ] i hope you don't mind but i i took
the liberty of borrowing the film you
brought
it
was how many times would you say you've
seen that movie
approximately i like the villain
the plot makes a real meal out of a
lunar god
and didn't you say that you worked for
one
production value of that film i can't
imagine that too many other people have
seen it
[Laughter]
and all i'm asking of you
is an honest assessment of your
situation
this is awesome god damn i know what
you're feeling you can be healed
i know
[Music]
don't hurt him all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
so good i love it what's the last thing
that you remember arrow shot
yeah yes exactly exactly all right we
gotta get out of here
oh come on gotta know open it is it jake
open everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
nice wow that was awesome that was the
best one yet i did not think the show
would go there that was wow ooh i'm like
so like sweaty and uncomfortable it's
like legion vibes too it was so intense
i genuinely don't know what reality
they're gonna land on they could really
go a lot of ways do we think it's jake
and that third sarcophagus
i think it's tony stark tony stark's
back tony stark is just in there trapped
in a tomb
i like that episode a lot back to my a's
that's that was incredible i have
theories i like that pace theories will
wait whose voice was that at the end i
don't know i don't think it was hers
what's the corresponding animal and
envisage for the god of music and love
oh yeah could be is it do we know any
hippopotamus-based gods i don't
that's that's why yeah
i'm like is
14 odd is that the whole that's what i
thought we were going to get was that
yeah actually when i think about this
show it seems like it's mainly based off
of this this company
this is what i would because this is a
cinematic i think i was like wow this is
very much and that's so i was like
surprised to be like oh damn we're going
all the way going
whoa because i i think the bendis
malevolent is really solid as well but
it's not as approachable and i also
think the cenkevich stuff is a lot of
the visual aesthetics they're doing but
it's not as approachable either i mean
stephen grant is like very different i'm
surprised they went there i really like
that i don't know it's not like the
fight club thing where you've got a
twist that is like now i know i mean
they gave a really good
there was one solid hint as to what's
happening he says it about like getting
passageway when they're going through
and they see the horus sign he says
they're going like a passageway to hell
or something oh
they're on a boat do you think that
water in the boat that's what the
rocking was like in the on the lights
and so do you think the afterlife is
i think there's no i think he's there
he's number one
the clapper board is like issue number
six or seven which is the actual
introduction yeah number one
that was the one i was like that's what
they're gonna do i think we should hold
them back because i feel like they're
just holding the issues
let's just let's just read the comics
but no i think that was the early clue
in in there that's that's great and
that's why i was like huh but i didn't
think they would do it yeah drifting
into the afterlife and then that wake up
was genius yeah i don't think they're on
a boat but they could be on like
something they're in water that is like
a water rocking that i think that's what
it's reflective of it could be way wrong
but that seemed like to be the biggest
indicator man
they're in a truck that's falling while
they're also here in the hospital i also
was not expecting the externalized two
marks and i was not expecting jake and i
mean mark and uh and and
i just forgot come on
the biggest episode of the season it's
jake is the one i want to see because
we've got mark stephen grant
guys sometimes
he was doing a [ __ ]
guys i'm so tired my brain just shows
like that's the time that's an authentic
time you are dragging
that's what it looks like that was like
your credit joke i can't tell the
difference between boys
save our credibility you don't know
comics
[ __ ] it's just funny to only read one
comic run of moon knight
this is the exact thing
i told you guys i think they're
basically off this run i was so like
overwhelmed with all this stuff i was
like there's a packing a lot and i told
you guys this is the right no you just
need the one i only gave you like 30
issues
yeah and they've done about 14. that's
definitely not the same thing though no
but it's just a lot yeah this is
definitely not the same there's a
clearer connective tissue to one
specific run than there often tends to
be yeah and it's just exciting because
john and i really get to have that
feeling
all the time
like i'm validating my weight yeah look
at me
there is
i can't tell you the amount of times
i've read comics and i've been like they
don't even do 99 of what's in the
comments that i read
so you do get that gratification you're
like oh that's so cool it feels great
when you're like i remember that from my
meetings i remember
yeah but most of the time we don't get
to say that so that's why it's exciting
drink it in it's not like we're cocky
and we know it all it's like this is the
rare
it's also literally like 100 issues and
they use like 12 but throughout the 100
so you have to read way more to really
get that feeling of like yeah and it's
exciting because i didn't expect them to
ever do that in the show i didn't either
i didn't think they'd go that far down
the rabbit hole where i was like whoa
because we're already into you know very
interesting gaps in reality with them
changing identities i didn't know if
they'd go full meets self existentially
yeah and also reality to the level of
life where does the show go in five and
six with this much up in the air earlier
in the episode
he's talking about like a riddle for
passage which seemed like it was
references to the moment my mind went to
a comic book specifically dealing with
something with passage he talks about
protection in the afterlife
so that's why i was like oh maybe we'll
actually go to the afternoon hear him
exclaim in the episode rewind yeah if
you'd like to see that moment it's 13
minutes in or so i'd be surprised if
they did it exactly the same way because
there's different plot setups to it the
a b and c of it is different than the d
e f of it you know what i mean so i
think it could
also the visualization of the thing
we're talking about is very different
so they could go that way or not i don't
know they did some visuals in the last
episode there's this there's this thing
in the comic called the void basically
even though that wasn't what we were
entering into in the last episode yeah
definitely had the cosmic array look and
the color palette yeah exactly so it
definitely felt like very referential to
it but instead of getting bogged down
and things that could be heavy potential
spoilers for what's to come let's just
talk specifically about what's going on
here i liked it way more than episode
three i thought it was a really that was
really strong like yeah this is about
what i liked it had that swashbuckling
tomb raider uncharted esque vibe i'm not
talking about the movie uncharted no you
really liked it but i'm not talking
about the movie uncharted more about
like the video game and i think that the
way they've woven these interpersonal
conflicts while moving the adventure
along is really strong i can imagine
that there's a part of the fan base
that's probably disappointed with the
way this show is going because you
barely get moon night in here like
you've barely got it moon i haven't
noticed you guys have mentioned that a
couple times and like it hasn't been a
thing for me because i don't read comics
for the punching
oh aren't you sophisticated no but like
i read it to look at the drawing i just
i liked
the ponder some like you know
existential musings on reality more than
i like the throwing punches so i don't
mind that moon knight is used as a means
to an end as opposed to the
characterization being the importance
yeah no absolutely i think that this er
what makes it strong is i'm more
invested in steven grant and mark
spector to the point where i don't find
myself going once he could have turned
into moon i want to punch it should
always be treated as like cherry on top
or necessary for plot development the
way they use them here like i don't i
don't miss it i'm not like where's the
suit that's when the show's most
interesting it's that someone that shows
most interesting to me and i think the
way they've really established the
relationship was right by the way i was
totally right i just predict that about
layla was totally right
yeah i was close
yeah he did he did not kill his life
but he was there and i thought you know
it worked out i mean the show alludes to
like yeah he should have died that night
and that's when which is fun for the
comic fans but beyond that like i think
even if you haven't read the comic
you're like oh that must be the night
when uh conscious saved him because
episode one is that a very event yeah so
it references the fact that like the
same day leila's father was killed and
mark was there as a mercenary it was
also the same day he made his pact with
koncho and that's also the event that
the people the the not cops when they
throw them in the back they reference
and show photos of like that's all this
event we've relived in various episodes
it's cool out there like as this mystery
unfolds you also get like the backstory
a little bit clearer without actually
cutting away to it and i keep wondering
if we're are we ever gonna see that
actual scene i like that we're not
because then it feels like we're living
through their adventure of it instead of
flashbacks always make me feel like i'm
watching something as opposed to in real
life we tell stories of a thing and
therefore you're with these characters
as soon as you do a flashback then
you're suddenly like oh right i'm
watching a medium like i'm watching an
art piece instead of watching a life
does that make sense yeah give me mike
flanagan's moon night yeah
lots of time version
well i keep wondering too with this like
plot reveal that they have here of the
psychiatry psychiatry hospital what
approach are they going to take because
as much as we've referenced a comic that
it's definitely pulling inspiration from
is it going to be the case where there
are actual souls trapped there like you
have this one guy there who sort of
looks like the what is that job called
john when someone isn't like gold paid
an outfit and i feel like you know the
name of it for some reason
that's what it's called everyone knows
but me
makes sense pretty aptly named
exactly what it is isn't it living
statue forget what they call the actual
little totems that they imprison the
gods into but that's yeah it's like a
little human version of that but i do
like the parallel of like a busker being
like a god that's imprisoned as a living
statue that's a fun thing well beyond
that it's the guy who's the living
stature in the first episode who mark
who stephen talks to
and then it looked like one of the guys
there was that guy might have been that
guy yeah so i don't know if it's like
these are actual people who are also in
this other world but then what threw me
off is the fact that mark is interacting
with steven as two separate entities who
can look at each other okay but maybe
this is just some weird world that mark
is trapped in now in his own head and
then their mess and then like egyptian
gods or whatever the imprisonment is
happening is
messing with him specifically or are
there or is like layla also there but
doesn't remember she's layla you know so
that that's what i'm wondering i don't
know which direction it's going to go i
also wonder if mark and stephen are
alternate realities of the same person
because we haven't really explored that
in this and marvel universe is starting
to do multiverse theory what if this is
a multiversal world where there is a
steven and a mark that are separate
leaning into the variants and leaning
into all those concepts it is an
interesting question
two hours
make it happen it does raise a lot of
implications because you do see
you know they're doing partly playing on
his own psychiatric state because it's
like okay here's everything we've seen
pretty much every prominent face here's
an origin for all those that could
motivate this being some kind of fantasy
or you could argue that maybe it's like
a parallel almost rhyming spirit realm
where not everybody is aware of their
earth circumstances or something like
that and i like that at least right now
that is mysterious and it seems like
certainly whatever is being presented
here as a mental hospital scenario isn't
true but i like that they've drawn it in
a way that is very sort of you can you
can look at it and interpret it and
anticipate it turning out multiple ways
but it still complements nicely with
everything else that's been going on
because if you look at you know the
motivation that arthur harrow and his
disciples have shown as much as there
are those like movie moments where they
get kind of dastardly for the most part
like the mission is still one of like
we've got to guide people and help heal
them and blah blah so like it it makes
sense that the counterparts might you
know translate into the people running
this joint for the powers that be it's a
nice adaptation but also a nice strong
metaphor visual plane to kind of move
forward from well what is ahmed's
deal again i'm totally freaking blinking
right now i'm hungry too but it's off
it's uh she basically is the one that
like punishes people before
their crimes which is his whole issue
with it i don't remember what she's
actually the god of that's yeah so could
ethan hawk in the psych hospital be
ahmed messing with him but why would
ahmet be doing that and why wouldn't
well she looked like an alligator no no
i'm not saying that the hippo was
i don't know what i'm saying that i
don't know who the hippo was i say
ahmed's in disguise as harrow yeah
maybe in this psych unit thing yeah it
all depends on on
what implications how much power
that you might have in this realm
carries over to the other row because
i'm like if she's got all the control
here and is able to orchestrate this
elaborate fantasy to imprison mark seems
like she could get a lot done on earth
you know yeah she can make this happen
yeah i need to deal with it she wouldn't
need an avatar yeah she's gonna get all
that done yeah yeah but maybe not i mean
maybe it is you know some or maybe it's
like she's puppeting his uh astral form
or something i don't know i also feel
like with marvel shows usually it's that
episode five cliffhanger that makes you
go like how do they wrap it up it's cool
to have this but at four like what's the
last movie of this because there's a
two-hour movie left effectively like why
does this all we're in a very different
place i think it would be very
disappointing for a lot of people if
this was all just in some guy's head i
don't think they'll do it was all a
dream
so painful for everything it would just
upset people
oh you just committed to that and
there's no actual moon night like yeah
if that was episode five maybe that
could happen but i feel like that's why
this happened on episode because they
have two episodes of the actual reality
so it is not a film a student thesis
film of like oh he's dreaming yeah cause
at five we have to spend a little bit of
time unraveling this assuming it could
be true and finding out it's not and
then climax and daniel mullen six that
being said
they you should stay here for a whole
episode i think i think you gotta like
do what the movie glass failed to do but
it might be fun to do like 40 of the 50
minutes here yeah at the end you
transition back to really make mark
wonder if he is crazy and like because i
felt very paranoid and uneasy in that
whole scene like i really enjoyed the
way they had the outside of the lenses
being disoriented and they played with
rack focus and they really made you feel
pulled and i definitely like that was
the disorientingly
almost paranoid high experience yeah
when i feel like this could make it a
good bridge to complementing and
ultimately tying up that question from
the first couple episodes which is that
you know did can't you choose you
because you're broken or did he break
you in choosing you and maybe the answer
we will discover through this is sort of
neither and maybe you know in having
these two personified personalities now
interacting separate of their host body
which is good therapy maybe yeah maybe
then they can see that it is neither and
they can use you know again uh the
struggle you know with the personality
as yeah part of the strength or come to
realize that self-actualize that you
know i mean this could be the void you
know where like conscious imprisoned
into yeah that could very much be like
where he's and then we get a
personification of him yeah yeah and i
think i think either he's in that
sarcophagus or jake is jake lockley
egyptian cab driver
[Laughter]
he said speak there yeah i think it's
very possible and maybe even likely like
we meet jake in the next episode he has
a fourth personality doesn't he
depending on the continuity so many
different i don't think he has more than
like six ever at once but he's got a lot
going on and then but i think the three
main ones are gonna be representing the
show cause there's so many threes in the
post-credits team there's three oscar
isaacs in the first scene in the uh in
the uh museum you see his reflection and
it's him plus two they've made three a
recurring number so i think jake lockley
is coming by the end yeah i don't think
the third is moon night because we have
two moon nights in mr night and moon
night i don't think the third is conshu
cause they've always been representative
of the image of oscar isaac so i think
they were trying to mislead us by
thinking that kanchu was the third
because the posters like the posters had
mr knight moon knight and then kanchu
but i think it's going to be three oscar
isaacs and therefore jake will come or
it's the guy who fights
werewolves in space
that's gonna be episode six
go into space
shameless connecting tissue yeah yeah i
mean what's interesting is he only
signed on like oscar isaac didn't sign
on for more after this yeah so if we get
more moon night it's going to be case by
case for him trusting the script and
wanting to be the character again so
it's going to be interesting where this
ends because it needs to be opened
enough for more oscar isaac but enough
closure that we have a story muhammad
said that moon knight's here to stay and
there will be more i i want that and i
think oscar isaac was smart so he could
renegotiate for me and make money he's
getting to do like between the khanshu
overwhelm in the last episode and the sh
and the shifts between him steven so
seamlessly like this is an actor's dream
if you're as talented as this actor well
funny enough actually as much as we've
talked about it i don't really miss moon
night or mr knight or feel like i'm
being deprived of those characters
really at all and i think this episode
brought that around really beautifully
because this episode had the gradual
pacing that i wish we we kind of
collectively expressed a wish for the
previous episode to bring and so this
one really wonderfully traversed scenes
added some icky horror stuff and then
brought it back around to a really
mind-bending emotional place all that
was like great i'm just with this and i
don't even need the suit well it also
did the thing we wanted like we were
talking about how that had to do a lot i
think we needed moon knight and mr
knight in the last one so this one could
not have both so this was the answer to
that and it's interesting because
muhammad's directing style is so capable
to have that tension and action densely
and then you get justin aaron who love
like inverted framing and a lot more
like
avant-garde style shots and that suits
this episode much better whereas mom had
suited the last episode better so i i
think it's really smart actually i was
worried at the top when i heard there
were three directors on this because i
was worried that the difference in
episodes would feel jarring but it's
positively jarring their styles suit
each storyline better
yeah i think the swashbuckling of this
episode is great i think uh the actress
who plays layla do you know her name i
don't
me
i think not sexist haha there's the
first scene with arthur yeah especially
and and the way they frame that they're
talking across a chasm beautiful i
forgot steven grant's name thank you
very much
character name on the show yeah that
shot was stunning that was like a
desktop background yeah and then the
close-ups on it like yeah so stunning
it's like a desktop pack it could be my
facebook cover i want to see it often
it's a desktop on my laptop i want to
put folders on top of that i'd like that
to be the dark void that is me opening
my computer because it makes me sad i
want to get used to that image and never
appreciate it i want to feel sorrow
yeah her performance was awesome when
yeah when she confronts stephen grant
too or mark in that moment this was like
a great epic i probably ranked this as
my second favorite what's your first
the first episode your favorite first
episode is still my favorite i would say
this is my second favorite episode that
lasts like 10 minutes i'd say
i also loved her in the last 10 minutes
where you're from his perspective
theoretically and how she's like
manipulative and selfish and how mark
might see her that way like if we're
looking at mark's view of her where
she's like we'll share this it's mine i
won like that whole play on how he might
perceive her is fun because we've only
seen her as selfless like she's been
killed
jada pinkett it's all her fault right
guys that's right so everyone says right
the only oscar i want to talk about is
isaac
the smacks in episode three when he was
like he like opened his fist and then
palmed the dude i was like again the
only oscar we're talking about his eyes
it was a pretty contained episode they
dropped pants at what's going on but
it's uh i mean we really really don't
know if they can't just pull from a
comic they would have to do some
different it's like the civil war thing
they're gonna nod to it heavily but the
thing that made it especially different
though but then again that is kind of
like the comic too with the two but
that's why i'm thinking multiversal is
an option to make it unlike the comic i
think they could go variants and
multiversal stuff because that's where
marvel is right now yeah i don't think
they will like that's not my expectation
i just think that option i wanted to say
it out loud because if it lands there
won't be like but i don't think that's
what they're doing i just want street
cred from right i do think if this
sticks the landing this is on par with
loki for me again like the way they're
navigating this dense of material is
insane what makes me curious is like if
this is ahmed's doing like it would be
weird if it was just some other god who
was doing this or something right if it
is ahmet's doing why would ahmed be
doing this to him when konchu's not even
a part of him anymore unless conscious
trapped there too and that is that realm
where everyone's stuck i don't think
ahmed's causing that afterlife i think
that's the afterlife i don't think
ahmed's responsible for that so this is
just like the like kind of like the
egyptian afterlife and that's how he
perceives it because oh
that's what i was ever saying protection
in the afterlife because the pen the pen
is a pen to him the pen is blue no no no
no no
[Music]
the pen is a pen to a harrow and the pen
is a chew toy to a dog the afterlife is
going to be perceived as mark would
perceive it versus how the egyptian gods
would perceive it ah yeah the pen oh
i think the perception of what reality
is is literally in the palm of your hand
and then the next episode dr strange
walks through and be like there's a lot
of variants in here
gets you all out of here
i put all my faith in the pen i was so
excited about my pen moment the pen is
mightier it's a fatalistic
this pen will only ever be a pillow me
martin i think we need to fight games
psychiatric perspective there's only one
reality where this isn't a pen
perspective
i think i think that's it i think the
pen is perspective itself i'm very
excited about that yeah there's a lot of
depth here man all right it shows a
weird day to film this yep we're all a
little slim
i think these are the longest reviews
we've done after episodes yeah it's the
show's fault did it say it's too good
it's too good man we only reach about a
half an hour yeah i'm gonna look for an
egg salad sandwich excellent
i want to go like meatball marinara sub
no you wow that's what i want around
this that's crazy yeah i'm leaning in
it's a lot of i want density i want
protein i want i'm all in just a tube
full of buffalo you can sell them four
days into a diet cause i've been eating
salads and juices and now i'm like
meatball marinara
pro time oh buffalo chicken artichoke
pizza too though yeah he didn't stop
talking for like a minute
subscribe click that bell
we watched what we were saying this time
around we'll catch you guys soon let's
do a patron of the day shout out
olivier
hamelin look what your name means and
guess what it's
olive tree it sounds a lot like
my fiance's name olivia which means
olive branch and a way
you two should be together when i watch
the show moon night and i think about
you know layla can be with both steven
grant and mark spector i could be the
mark specter in the situation and you
could be the stephen grant that's right
buddy i'm inviting you your sexy reject
into a polyamorous relationship with us
i think the time has come for us to take
that next step just by virtue of your
name what does a branch connect to a
tree
you are the tree trunk to our
relationship so olivia before you say no
just know this i will gladly never get
involved in the bedroom if that means
i can emotionally have you because
that's what matters most i don't know
what you look like i don't know what you
behave like i don't know what you sound
like i don't know anything about you
really but i do know that we are a
perfect triangular fit
he's sexy so i'm a [ __ ]
please don't cancel me
[Music]